[Music]
almost impractical you know the guy the
President of the United States pardoning
himself would just be unthinkable and it
would it would lead to probably an
immediate impeachment you know you get
you the house now Senate beyond the
tremendous tremendous pressure President
Trump has no need to do that you do
anything wrong
thankfully the president hasn't done
anything wrong and wouldn't have any
need for a pardon all right let's talk
about it with our panel match slap
contributor with the hill a B Stoddard
associate editor at Real Clear Politics
and guy Benson political editor at
townhall.com welcome to all of you hey
Shannon okay so the president has
tweeted a lot as he always does and he
says listen I've been told by numerous
legal scholars I have the absolute right
to pardon myself but why would I do that
when I've done nothing wrong Matt yeah
this this is basically all what they
call the political question you're the
lawyer I'm not but the idea that we'd
even be in a place where the president
would be pardoning himself and maybe it
goes to the nation's highest court I
think what what the president is really
trying to say is this that there are a
lot of constitutional questions about
everything that's happened in this whole
controversy including spying on the
executive branch spying on members of
the opposing campaign lots of questions
here and he's saying I'm gonna fight
fire with fire
you're doing things that I view as extra
constitutional including having a
special counsel that's acting more like
a senate-confirmed
actor in the Department of Justice and
he's saying I'm gonna fight it with the
powers I have as well all right I wanna
play a little bit of what Senator Ed
Markey had to say about this here's his
take it's not a rule of Trump it's a
rule of law that we live under in the
United States of America even back in
1974 Richard Nixon's Justice Department
made it quite clear that Nixon could not
harden himself the same thing is true
here okay and a B he's referring to memo
that was written by then acting
assistant attorney general Mary Lawton
who said under the fundamental rule that
no one can be a judge in his own case
the president cannot pardon himself 1974
right Nixon hoped that it would be
possible but it wasn't this this is a
really remember were we're in the middle
a spin war of a political campaign that
Rudy Giuliani is waging in in the press
on behalf of Donald Trump at his request
to spin things a certain way so as to
form the opinions among Trump supporters
and others and congressional Republicans
who are supine and completely
acquiescent at this point but they
disagree on some of these points that I
don't have I don't hear anyone today
fighting the pardon thing Cruz Ted Cruz
says guy and I were just discussing went
silent for 18 seconds when asked if it
was constitutional for the president to
fire himself and he having boasted that
he meant the constant departing himself
I'm sorry chuck Grassley and pushback
they said well if that was my lawyer I'd
get a new one sounds like a pushback it
was not we are here of taking an oath to
the Constitution and not the man he is
not allowed to do this
these are nearly dictatorial powers he's
describing in that twenty page memo and
in his tweets this morning and that is
out of line no one pushed back that hard
they called it a distraction bob Corker
wondered why he talks this way which
takes away from the from the subjects of
the day Shannon let's get back to the
fact that the Trump team completely lied
about the Trump Tower meeting
description that the president gave when
he dictated a false statement they know
Bob Muller has that they know that mark
Hollow who was on the Trump legal team
temporarily left because he believed a
cover-up was in the hatching and he is
testified to more about that okay let me
know Josh Rafael let some of this down
and hope it breaks them in his dad was
correct this is one of the things that
Rudy Giuliani said about why heat it was
doesn't want the president to testify
because he says if you remember things
differently if the accounts change guy
that creates a lot of problems even if
there is an innocent explanation for
everything about who dictated the letter
what input the president had it seems
the story has changed but Giuliani says
no Jay got this wrong but this is why I
don't want them interviewing the
president well the story has absolutely
changed and they said no it didn't
happen and now in the letter that they
sent I guess in January they admit that
it did that's not good that hurts their
credibility there's no question about
that to me as I look back and I'm
looking at these clips and watching them
from Rudy on the
day shows in the tweet from the
president sort of gaming out self
pardons I'm sitting here thinking what
what on earth are we doing here why are
we listening to the president and his
team speculate in real-time about
whether he might do something that they
then hasten to add oh he'll never have
to do it to me it's an obvious that's a
crazy hypothetical it would never come
to that next question no comment but
instead Trump doubles down and says you
bet I can do it which is why we're all
sitting here debating the finer points
of whether than whether or not the
president could hypothetically get to
that point why but Matt again he says
there's no need for it but he wants to
be on the record saying that I believe
because of what legal scholars have told
me I would be right to do this yeah I
think there's a hinge here there's a
question about what are the president's
limits of his pardon power but there's
also this whole question about whether a
president can be indicted and I think
what the founders in the writers of our
Constitution envisioned is that a
politician the head of our government
the president United States chief
executive the best way to handle these
questions is the impeachment process
through the house and with conviction in
the Senate and all these questions about
whether the president could be indicted
it hinges on this question of pardons
and it also hinges on this final
question this is really important we
have Bob Muller acting much more like a
senate-confirmed officer of the
Constitution and not like somebody who
was picked to do a discrete task and
that's the real question here is Bob
Muller being managed is he able to pull
people onto his team at his discretion
if that's the case he should be
confirmed by the Senate
that's a substantial constitutional
question that we're not talking about
all right
maybe use the word dictatorial which you
know that's gonna upset a lot of people
when they talk about this but they
really do okay nearly dictatorial
its qualified but the Constitution does
have as Matt talked about this framework
for impeachment so if there are enough
people convinced that this president is
out of line whether he's committed a
crime or not whether he's part of
himself or not they still have a means
it's not he's not limitless in his power
there's still a way to rein him in if
the lawmakers are convinced that's nice
but it but between the memo and his
tweets he's basically saying I can
terminate this at any time I can't be
indicted
I can pardon myself I used the words
absolute right and he is presenting
himself as a
of this investigation let alone the laws
that confront it there they are
preparing and we've talked about this at
this table for months now Rudy Giuliani
is preparing a political campaign in
order to stave basically saying he can't
be indicted he can only be impeach but
what they're doing with the reason I
raise the Trump Tower meeting and the
statement about it is because they know
that Muller perceives it to be an
obstruction of justice and it's likely
to be presented in the report that way
so the letter from January with those
assertions is designed to say but you
can't even really assess it as a
obstruction of justice because he can't
obstruct the law and so with its what
he's he's saying to congressional
Republicans is you can't even impeach
him for obstruction of justice because
impeachment political question that's
exactly right
but it's not like yesterday that people
decided that there had to be a PR
component to the political fights that
they're waging here in DC that's as old
as time correct and I'm part of it I
would also note that we're all sort of
analyzing in granular detail the
contents of this letter this 20 page
letter that went out in January almost
that entire legal team is gone now so
you could argue that some of the
assertions that they made in there are
absolute at this point which is why I'm
still baffled why Rudy and others would
even indulge this conversation about
self pardons that is a distraction right
now it's getting way ahead of anything
and yet they sort of threw that Chum in
the water or at least responded to the
bait from the press and then Trump
doubled down I just don't think that
does him much of a service here well we
will see there's an Inspector General
report due out any day we've got the
molar investigation and many others
congressional bodies and yet the
president hasn't fired any of these
folks yet so we will see